so each piece of DLC has conveyed
something in the first few minutes
sunken crown had a long crooked hallway
that projected the sense that you were
traveling into a long-forgotten ancient
and crumbling Kingdom the iron crown DLC
gave us wander that long walk along the
chain imparted a sense of curiosity just
like it was meant to do in the story
because the story was about all these
Knights who came here to reclaim the
replete stores of iron ivory crown
doesn't disappoint either the cold
barren landscape the biting wind the
oppressive view of this massive castle
the ivory crown to me screams go back
you're not wanted here and the visuals
aren't the only thing telling you to go
back some voices as well naturally we
press forward because how hard could it
be pretty bad it turns out you went to
the first fog gate you see and some
voice starts rambling on about how
you're going to die it's really really
condescending but what does she know I'm
the chosen undead mother oh that's giant
invisible tiger yep I'm dead deer this
dialogue and this death has a purpose
though it should make you mad it should
make you curious because just before you
died you heard this woman talking about
how you don't have a sign and so finding
this thing this sign that can help you
defeat this tiger that becomes the focus
of your irritation it gives you an
objective it's one thing to give you an
objective but it's another thing to work
that objective into the game play the
souls games are good at this and Dark
Souls 2 does it here this DLC does a
good job of building intrigue we see
these white maidens kneeling and you
instinctively feel this sense of
curiosity about them personally I left
them alone but I know a lot of players
are going to go through the first time
and just attack them out of curiosity
regardless of whether you're a kind
player or a cruel one both of you will
learn to ignore the maidens because
ultimately they don't do anything they
don't drop anything
and as a result they'll become as
featureless and as unimportant as all
the snow you trampled upon
it's somewhere in the back of your mind
and the game wants this to happen to you
the game wants you to forget about these
maidens but more on that later
speaking of enemies though the biggest
criticism I can find for this DLC and
all the other lost crown trilogy DLCs is
how boring the standard enemies are the
first DLCs enemies are soldiers slightly
taller than me and poison covered the
second are soldiers slightly taller than
me burnt and covered in iron the third
main soldier is again slightly taller
than me and covered in ice you get the
point while I get that these technically
suit the environment you know they're a
product of their environment it does
seem a bit uninspired when every enemy
seems to be using a similar model and it
just feels like the same enemy in
different skins it's believable don't
get me wrong it just got old quickly
only the main enemies are boring in this
way though and there's plenty of other
enemies that were actually interesting
in some way for example from software
brings back will skeletons 2.0 in the
form of these cute little rat dudes and
they also have these enemies that come
to life if you kill another enemy near
them which forces you to use really good
positioning and choose the location you
have your fights in they even made their
red phantom AI even better
I mean seriously creativity in the way
that they use red phantoms now it's at a
whole new high we were all impressed in
the first DLC when we saw just a Thomas
do a gesture and in the second DLC we
all cried out in frustration when we
fought mal during the assassin but these
phantoms in the third DLC man the moment
that you meet the first red phantom is
priceless and there's a lot of funny
things that these phantoms will do that
you just expect a human player to do you
know so while I might spoil a lot of
things in this video if there's anything
I don't want to spoil it's what that red
phantom does to you there's no way I'm
spoiling that moving on to an analysis
of how you move through the level you'll
remember in the iron crown DLC you
actually had to go past areas you'd
already been to in order to access
platforms that were moving
weren't moving before and in the ivory
crown DLC you also have to do this to an
extent you have to go through the level
later on to see things you missed and to
access previously inaccessible parts the
first time you go through many paths and
items are frozen or blocked by ice so
once it melts you have to remember the
places where there was ice before so you
can access it the second time through
now they handled this second run really
well in some ways and badly in others
but ultimately I came away pretty
disappointed with it I mean it's a way
for them to pad out the experience
you're going through the same areas
you're fighting the same enemies and
because the main enemies are really
boring and standard and I fought them a
lot in the previous DLCs I didn't really
enjoy this experience it rewards the
player who took note of their
surroundings because those players are
the ones that are going to remember
which way to go which is good I like
that
I think that's a great thing to reward
but the problem I have with that is that
my surroundings were so damn boring that
I barely remembered them snowy outdoor
area empty brick indoor area snowy
outdoor area with a fountain brick
indoor area with a torch
you get the gist this is OK
aesthetically I suppose I mean it is
meant to be a really cold and barren
landscape but when a part of the
gameplay actually requires you to
remember these emotionless areas and
when a part of the gameplay actually
requires you to go through these areas
again I think it's fairly unforgiveable
that the environments were really really
bland you know exploring more bland
emotionless rooms isn't very motivating
and going through it again felt a bit
forced for me you might feel differently
but I usually love snowy aesthetics the
painted world of ariamis in Dark Souls 1
is actually my favorite area but I think
they did a poor job of making me care
about the environments and the enemies
here and I think it could have been done
better your second playthrough isn't all
bad though they introduced some really
cool gameplay elements because one of
the highlights is fighting those ice
maidens again you remember how I said
that those ice maidens faded into the
background before you know they didn't
do anything so you either killed
or you either ignored them completely
well they punish you for ignoring them
completely now ignoring them is
something that will get you killed
because now that the castle is warmer I
think those ice maidens must have thawed
out or something because now they will
get up after you pass and in true Dark
Souls fashion go up behind you and
backstab you just for forgetting about
them and you know it is so easy to
forget about them they didn't have a
purpose the first time you went through
and so you might find that they start to
punish you if you keep forgetting about
them their addition to the second
playthrough of the level was a nice
surprise and I think it's a way to add a
new enemy that was there all along it's
a great example of from software playing
you as a player they're training you to
expect one thing only for them to change
it on you later on in the hopes that it
gets you killed
your expectation is your biggest
weakness for example the burnt ivory
King boss actually punishes you for
being persistent the first time you
fight him whereas every other boss
rewards persistence the giant iron
warriors in the iron crown DLC had
spouts of flame that stopped you
circling around them and strafing and
trying to attack them from the back they
forced you to fight them head-on instead
many DLC black phantoms also punish you
for prioritizing their death when
they're running away and the enemies in
the sunken crown DLC also had really
high poise all of these are examples of
from gaining a lot from challenging your
conventions they're challenging your
expectations and as a result experienced
players might find their experience
working against them and and that's a
really good way of making the
experienced player have trouble with
something moving on to the bosses which
is my favorite part of the ivory crown
DLC just because they were presented in
a really cool way there seems to be a
pattern when it comes to bosses in the
DLC there's always two great bosses and
always one terrible boss the same rings
true in the ivory crown except the two
good bosses are incredible and the third
boss that is usually terrible is it's
not that bad it's still bad but it's not
terrible so the first good boss that
you're going to encounter is the Kings
at Alva it's a tiger with a limited
moveset but it has really punishing
attacks so while you pick up on its
attacks pretty quickly you'll also get
punished if you don't learn its attacks
you know it's a really long fight as
well so it's one of those things where
you have to be consistent and mistakes
aren't tolerated the best thing about it
is the fact that it's not a humanoid
enemy I feel like in Dark Souls 2 way
too many bosses consisted of humanoid
designs and I'm really happy to see
another monster boss moving on to the
final boss I don't think anyone will
disagree with me when I say that the
final boss is easily the highlight of
the dlc if not the entire game you've
spent the last few hours freezing in a
white wasteland only to learn that the
King ventured below his kingdom long ago
to fight an ancient enemy and he never
returned you go through a fog gate only
to fall and a dramatic color transition
takes place which is timed perfectly
with the music as you land on a small
platform among the roiling lava while
the king's surviving knights fight
alongside you with their corrupted
brothers and against their lost king and
that's just the setup the fight itself
has a good flow to it though I will say
that it is a little bit too difficult on
the first attempt because you actually
have to travel back through the entire
DLC to find the King's old Knights to
help you with this fight your first
attempt will likely be a death to teach
you that you need to go back through the
DLC and just generally as a rule I'm
never a fan of when you need a mandatory
death in order to learn something I
think it's a way for the gameplay to
teach you something but it's a little
bit too harsh in my opinion you need to
go back through the DLC and you need to
find those four Knights to fully realize
just how good this fight can be and once
you do that it's a great experience the
King looks a little bit generic I
suppose and he has a really plain
moveset but the presentation is the
highlight of this fight and that fall
down to the fight gave me the best
holy-shit moment in the entire game I
also think that the coop area was one of
the best ones so far you guys know that
I've complained about them in the
previous DLCs but
one actually uses gameplay to make you
feel incredibly lost as a result you
have an actual feeling of companionship
and warmth that comes from having a
partner as you brave the snowstorm
together this is the first DLC that
actually made it so that you're not just
fighting more enemies with your co-op
partner you're going through an area
where having a partner means more than
just being able to kill a lot of enemies
together you might actually do it for
that feeling of companionship or feeling
less lost or having an actual guide you
know when you finally get to the boss
fight and I mean finally because it
takes a hell of a long time to get to
this boss you realize that it's a double
fight which I generally dislike because
I think that everything should be fair
solo and double boss fights just aren't
you know they're always going to benefit
from having a partner to fight them with
just because you can split their
attention but if you accept that it's
meant to be fought with someone else or
that it's a better fight with someone
else then it's a really good experience
it's to Ava's which makes sense because
the King had multiple pets but I think
it also would have been better if the
pets were different creatures fighting
the same boss that you've already fought
once but there's two of them in this
time is not a really good experience
it's not that creative and since the
blizzard that you have to go through
before you get to the boss fight is one
of the longest hardest stretches in the
entire game most players will find
themselves thinking why am i fighting
this again I just walked for like 20
minutes to get to this boss and I've
already fought it before is it really
worth going through all that hardship
just to fight this boss most of us don't
play for the reward we get when we kill
bosses we play for the experience and
fighting two of the same boss isn't a
particularly good one that said my first
encounter was actually a lot of fun with
them I managed to get at first go but I
can imagine a lot of people who didn't
get a first go would be really
disillusioned with
five because you fight the first one and
it takes a while to get him down to half
health and then the second one spawns so
as soon as you get the first one down to
50% health 40% health you have to finish
him off really quick before the second
one gets there and there's a lot of rng
in actually being able to speed through
that bosses health you know what if he
dodges you a lot or something like that
I was lucky because I could damage him a
lot and I got stuck underneath him and I
could kill him real quick but most
people won't and most people will end up
fighting two of the same creature which
just makes the fight not good it forces
you to play defensively and it's just
not fun to fight two enemies like that
enough negativity though one thing
that's great about all the boss
experiences in the dlcs is the music you
might not notice the music while you're
fighting for your life but trust me the
osts they have for these fights are
standouts above everything else than the
rest of the game in my opinion anyway I
might be exaggerating but I reckon that
music is so perfect for the bosses that
I reckon you could guess which boss the
music is for just by listening to the
tone of the music seriously check it out
I'll have a few links in the description
the story is another highlight it's
presented in a way that has Hamas
the previous game it has implications
for the rest of Dark Souls 2 as well and
it's also a story that can stand well on
its own I'll be going into detail later
in a proper video which I'm really
looking forward to it's a really good
story but one thing I don't understand
is why they haven't introduced any new
characters this game was always lacking
it's solare it didn't have an Estrada
it didn't have a siegmeyer you know none
of the characters were super standout
and I think they missed an opportunity
to have a character going through the
dlc with us and also they missed an
opportunity for a character to provide
some much-needed exposition someone to
explain what was going on in terms of
the story in terms of game design
characters are often the most difficult
things to coordinate with the design of
your game because they involve working
your story around the various lines of
dialogue recorded by a voice actor and
that limits the amount of changes that
can be made if you have a set voice
already recorded you know what if the
gameplay changes and that voice becomes
obsolete it can be difficult to work
around so I'll blame the lack of good
characters in this DLC on time
restraints I have a feeling they would
have done it if they could I'm also
going to be doing a separate video on
the ending we get after we collect all
the crowns my short review of collecting
all the crowns in every piece of DLC is
that it raises as many questions as it
answers and unfortunately that leaves a
lot of gaps in the law that we were
hoping would be explained and that I am
hoping will be answered in future DLCs
although I'm not holding my breath for
any more DLC in the end though all three
pieces of DLC are incredible value if
you enjoyed Dark Souls 2 you'll enjoy
them if you enjoyed Dark Souls 1 you'll
especially enjoy them because I think
that every one of them offers something
to a different player
I think they stand out significantly in
terms of quality from the base game but
I'm curious why do you think that is is
it the level design that's complex and
has short cuts rather than straight
paths is it the bosses that have a
really unique element to each one of
them maybe it was the overall
presentation let me know in the comments
below I'm really curious to know what
you think there's also a poll you can
vote in in the description and I
encourage you to look at it to see what
other people in the community think
about the DLC results from the last poll
show that most people rated the iron
crown DLC a 9 or an 8 out of 10 and I'd
really like to see how you think the
ivory crown matches up because community
votes are really important too it's not
just my opinion but other than that guys
thanks for watching I'll see you in the
next one and I promise more good stuff
is on the way bye bye